[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sûreté des 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mercredi 15 novembre
lancement aujourd'hui à saint quentin en
yvelines le troisième festival saint
quentin organisé par tv 78 des buts cinq
jours de programmation sur tout le
territoire autour du film documentaire
est la soirée d'ouverture a lieu ce soir
à l'ugc skywest en présence du
compositeur vladimir cosma et nous
serons sur place
dans un instant il brille à près de 300
mètres de hauteur le phare de la tour
eiffel a été rénové le signal lumineux
symbole du rayonnement de paris a été
rallumée en octobre après un mois et
demi de sommeil et c'est une entreprise
yvelinoise qui a effectué cette
modernisation zone dans cette édition
et puis c'est une aventure sportive et
humaine le 16e raid amazones se déroule
du 1er au 11 décembre au cambodge au
menu de la compétition 100 % féminine
course à pied vtt et canoë kayak 7
yvelinois seront sur la ligne de départ
dont les et crazy mothers pour une
première participation
elles sont nos invités en début de ce
journal par une bonne nouvelle le jeune
lucien a été retrouvé sain et sauf ce
matin est depuis hier à 8h30
l'adolescent de 16 ans était signalée
disparue à fontenay le fleury pour le
commissariat de plaisir il s'agit
vraisemblablement d'une fugue
c'est un rendez vous organisé par mtv 78
le troisième festival saint quentin
débute officiellement ce soir
événement dédié aux films documentaires
jusqu'à dimanche à saint quentin en
yvelines
bonsoir nicolas kirilow vite ça vous
êtes sur place à l'ugc et skywest et
dans quelques minutes début de la
cérémonie d'ouverture de ce festival qui
a pour thème cette année la musique
pour soirée n'aurait en effet la musique
est à l'honneur cette année la musique
sous tous ses aspects que ce soit à
travers le parcours d'un artiste de son
importance pédagogique dans nos vies ou
même de son importance historique pour
de nombreuses communautés et pour
débuter ce festival à l'ugc et skyways
dans quelques instants le célèbre
compositeur de musique de film vladimir
cosma sera mise à l'honneur
vous le connaissez forcément vladimir
cosma puisqu'il a composé notamment la
musique d'un dîner de cons de rabbi
jacob ou encore de la boum pour ne citer
qu'eux une soirée autour d'un piano pour
retracer le parcours de l'artiste
et pour en parler nous sommes avec le
directeur de l'ugc à mes côtés marc
albaut grave s vont soir détaillé nous
un petit peu cette cette soirée comment
elle va se dérouler concrètement je veux
parler d'une d'une soirée autour d'un
piano c'est de ça dont il s'agit
alors oui il n'ya pas que ça y'a pas
qu'un piano vu qu'en première partie il
y aura l'ensemble musical de
montigny-le-bretonneux qui va jouer et
pendant une demi heure trois quarts
d'heure des musiques de films dont on ne
savait pas mais une musique de valdimir
kosma donc il sera en salle et un trait
il ya la lumière cosma qui va présenter
un documentaire un peu sur son oeuvre
sur sa vie sur ses compositions et il va
interagir avec patrice carmouze au piano
discuter de ses compositions
voilà pendant toute la soirée on entend
justement les répétitions ont débuté ce
soir pour la première soirée vous faites
vous fait je crois ça comble c'est un
bon signal pour la pour la suite du
festival forcément alors oui c'est un
bon signal on a à peu près 400 personnes
ce soir qui seront présents dans la
salle les soirs c'est l'ouverture mais
le festival a commencé dès ce matin avec
des premières projections de films et de
documentaires à l'ugc ou pour l'instant
le public répond présent
évidemment il y en aura encore pendant
jusqu'à dimanche des films à le jcp être
un mot sur votre partenariat avec ceux
avec ce festival c'est pas la première
année c'est une affaire qui est on va
dire qu'il commença à entrer dans les us
et coutumes c'est une affaire qui roule
entre vous alors écoutez ça va faire
maintenant la troisième année c'est un
festival qu'on a imaginé avec thierry
barbeau n'atteint de tv 78
donc c'est vrai qu'on voulait créer un
événement au niveau de l'agglomération
pour essayer de fédérer un peu toutes
les forces au niveau de la culture donc
c'est la troisième édition dédiée à la
musique on a déjà fait l'environnement
notamment au niveau de la coque 21 on a
fait une manière le sport et cette année
on voulait vraiment créer quelque chose
de très fédérateur autour de la musique
où tout le monde va se retrouver et avec
des moments très forts notamment à l'ugc
avec des moments classique des moments
un peu plus moderne et notamment deux
événements classiques
1 le vendredi soir avec les enfants de
verdi ou la hausse y aura une cantatrice
qui viendra en salle jouée au canot avec
les enfants de trappes pour chanter du
verdi et dimanche après-midi vous aurez
un opéra ballet qui s'appelle les amants
magnifiques qui sera retransmis à l'ugc
merci alban grave s pour ces précisions
donc vous l'aurez compris grégory
dernière petite précision d'ailleurs sur
le programme on peut se rendre sur le
site internet du festival
c'est jusqu'à dimanche en tout cinquante
manifestations sont prévues donc ici
évidemment à l'ugc skate mais aussi en
partenariat avec l'ue vs q le grenier à
sel et le ciné 7 d'elancourt merci à
vous nicolas et à patrick jacques de
dixmude aux moyens techniques la soirée
de clôture de ce festival elle se tient
c'est ce dimanche au ciné c'est
d'elancourt dès 16 heures avec une
remise des prix et chaque jour à partir
de demain sur tv soixante dix huit
nouveaux à proposant la diffusion de
documentaires consulter la programmation
de ce festival saint quentin sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
et dans l'actualité également les
pompiers des yvelines prix est de plus
en plus pour cible les agressions en
exercice ont augmenté de 34% dans le
département entre 2015 et 2016 et des
données publiées par l'institut national
des hautes études de la sécurité de la
justice et les pompiers zibeline on en
subit 39 agression l'an passé en plus de
110 mille interventions chiffrement
pour le syndicat unsa s 10 78 propos
collectées par nicolas kirillovitch on
les visées par des quand on s'appelle
des pavés à part déjà et de gros pétards
peut-être à venir cocktails molotov
les attaques sont de plus en plus
violente ordonné en france et violente
envers la police envers les pompiers on
verra confié pascal bon voilà c'est
l'état ensher dépend pas d'eux des trams
et c'est l'état c'est les pompiers on
est en uniforme
on gèle on efface sujets qui y ont
d'ailleurs peut-être comme la légende de
l'armée de la police de la gendarmerie
et on veut pas le voir dans les
quartiers parce que ben on va dire ayant
une bêtise peut-être mais on représente
la france
souvenez vous c'était il ya un an une
polémique à voisins le bretonneux autour
de la réouverture du centre de placement
de la protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse est les riverains craignent est
à l'époque la présence de ces jeunes
ayant commis à des délits elle nous
avons poussé la porte du site et
rencontrer les résidents et éducateurs
un reportage de nicolas landry bientôt
midi david et youssef met la table
ces deux mineurs sorti de détention ont
été placés sur décision du juge dans
l'unité hébergement diversifié renforcé
de voisins-le-bretonneux ont formaté
dans ma chambre
je chante ici à ccc par angèle qui
m'arrange et la face au mans dit ça
c'est la tâche de sang sont toujours
projet justement youssef lui à 15 ans de
nationalité marocaine il vient de sortir
de détention
il est arrivé le 7 novembre dernier dans
l'établissement elle cherche travail gfr
ces deux jeunes préparent leur repas un
atelier cuisine mené par un éducateur et
une cuisinière au menu poisson pané et
salades crudités retrouvent à la cuisse
en mai on retourne d'accord cet
établissement spécialisé dans la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse
accueille des jeunes de 13 à 21 ans
plusieurs modalités de prise en charge
l'hébergement résidence éducative des
résidant en appartement partagé ou des
jeunes en famille d'accueil
accueillant journée sur le site objectif
l'accompagnement à la réinsertion
sociale et professionnelle
cet établissement la correspondent plus
aux nouvelles orientations de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse qui
souhaite que nous arrivions à différents
dieux pardon diversifier les modalités
de prise en charge afin de pouvoir
proposer des
d accueil qui se rapproche le plus des
besoins des besoins des jeunes
actuellement dix jeunes sont placés dans
l'unité d'hébergement quatre ans
résidence éducative dont david et
youssef à terme une vingtaine de
résidants devraient occuper cette unité
on vous en parlait lundi dans le journal
le deuxième colloque familles d'ici et
d'ailleurs se tenait hier au théâtre de
fontenay le fleury rendez vous tout de
tout pour tous les professionnels de
l'enfance du socialo médicales en
passant par l'éducatif thème cette année
vulnérabilité et résilience autrement
dit était abordé la question de la
fragilité de l'enfant mais aussi de sa
capacité à faire face à des situations
difficiles
journée animée par de nombreux
spécialistes venus du monde entier ce
qui a permis d'avoir des éclairages
multiples des propos recueillis par
patrick jacques de dixmude en france
quand vous parlez de radicalisation vous
parlez de radicalisation islamique donc
vous parler uniquement de radicalisation
religieuse
or nous au québec et au canada lé
considérons que les majorités sont aussi
radicaliser que les minorités avec la
montée des extrêmes droites la montée et
néo nazis et des suprémacistes blancs et
que donc ça se joue dans sainte est
interaction entre les deux donc vous
voyez ces différences de représentation
du phénomène des radicalisations a
énormément d'importance en terme des
systèmes cliniques de la façon dont on
va penser la situation en intervention
la tour eiffel symbole de paris mais
aussi figure de la france et que serait
la dame de fer son sofa visible depuis
la capitale est sur une bonne partie de
l'île de france le signal lumineux a
subi récemment une cure de jouvence pour
la première fois depuis 2000 une
modernisation assurée par une entreprise
yvelinois ses salariés ont travaillé à
près de 300 mètres de haut pendant six
semaines camille lambert et nicolas dans
le riz
ils ont joué les gustave eiffel pendant
six semaines douze techniciens de la
société rambo liten à devait
mécatronique ont rénové le système
électronique du phare de la tour eiffel
parmi eux michel des landes technicien
depuis 35 ans dans cette entreprise
la difficulté c'est les changements à
chaque fois de phares de descendre au
monte escalier escalier sur des échelles
d escalier en colimaçon
c'est vrai que c'était assez épuisant ça
un sort d un petit peu les habitudes de
travail
on évolue on trouvait donc je serai un
très gros projet très intéressant
installé depuis 2000 certaines pièces
étaient obsolètes des pannes régulières
une rénovation nécessaire de la mise en
mouvement du phare la première demande
et et ça c'était de faire une mise à
jour électronique et une mise à jour de
la mécanique du phare pour pouvoir aussi
préparer les évolutions les dix
prochaines années
la motorisation électronique la
spécialité d'a2m mécatronique depuis
cette société a remporté l'appel
d'offres face à une quinzaine
d'entreprises candidates
elle a fait valoir son expérience suite
à une première intervention passé sur la
tour eiffel
il ya bien quatre phares comme chacun
des quatre points cardinaux
chacun des quatre phares éclairent sur
les 90 degrés et lorsqu'il a fini ses 90
premier degré il passe la main ou par
suivant est institué pour donner
l'illusion qu'il y a qu un sofa une
illusion qui permet à la dame de fer de
conserver certains secrets sous sa
longue robe d'acier à mettre en lien les
acteurs publics privés et les
associations pour faire face à des
problématiques locales
tout l'enjeu de trappes territoire
vivant c'est une alliance créée entre la
ville l'association en vie et le groupe
auchan hier une première journée de
travail se tenait à la mairie de trappes
images signées nicolas kirillovitch
thématique l'insertion professionnelle
au programme échanges et recherche de
solutions concrètes
les entreprises locales se plaignent de
ne pas avoir de candidat et que les
jeunes aux locales se plaignent de ne
pas avoir d'emploi donc déjà
la problématique de l'emploi a émergé de
cette confrontation là et puis du fait
qu' on s'est rendu compte que l'on ne
travaillait pas assez nos entreprises
avec l'éducation nationale avec les
entreprises call inverse on est les les
entités associative les acteurs publics
n'étaient peut-être pas assez proche de
nous et qu'il fallait à un moment donné
se rassembler pour travailler ensemble
prochaine thématique qui pourraient être
abordés par cette nouvelle alliance
territoriales les questions du logement
et de la culture l'agriculture des
yvelines elle engagée dans l'agro
écologie c'est en tout cas ce que prouve
le certificat iso 14001 qui a été
renouvelé jeudi dernier pour plusieurs
exploitants du département
cette norme environnementale récompense
les démarches menées pour par les
agriculteurs en matière d'écologie les
précisions de camille lambert
depuis cinq ans il fait la fierté de son
directeur se méthaniseur permet de
transformer le lisier et le fumier des
animaux de la ferme de la tramblais en
biogaz
il devient lui-même de l'électricité
puis du chauffage avec d'autres mesures
elle a permis à la ferme d'obtenir le
certificat iso 14001 une norme pour
appuyer son engagement en faveur de
l'environnement puisque nous oblige donc
à avoir
une méthodologie à gérer des non
conformités à communiquer auprès du
personnel pour dire voilà pourquoi on
fait ça au personnel de ne répondre mais
il nous manque que ceux-ci ceci pour
améliorer notre façon de protéger
l'environnement dans ce type de démarche
interactive reçu en 2006 son certificat
a été renouvelé comme elle une dizaine
d'autres firmes chinoises ont obtenu
leur renouvellement des exploitants qui
favorise l'agroécologie regroupés au
sein de l'association terre des yvelines
un autre groupe a pris conscience de ce
besoin de communiquer ce besoin de
certifier nos performances des
indicateurs concrets validée par un
bureau extérieur qui vient dire voilà
c'est un victor la respecte la
réglementation au mieux en place des
actions à vocation environnementale et
vont dans le bon sens
le produit du blé de colza je ne
travaille plus le seul donc je laboure
plus pour favoriser la vie et finalement
dans le sol et peut schématiser grosso
modo ben jeu
préserve les vers de terre qui est
finalement enrichissent le sol
christian n'utilise plus de produits
chimiques et s'ennuie il sert dans le
btp pour produire de l'électricité et de
la chaleur
terre des yvelines espèrent toucher de
nouveaux exploitants pour favoriser une
agriculture durable dans le département
le sport c'est une aventure physique est
avant tout humaine la 16e édition du
raid amazones et débute le 1er décembre
au cambodge une compétition
exclusivement réservée aux femmes
au programme six jours d'épreuves course
à pied vtt ou encore canoë kayak à
travers des paysages magnifiques et
notamment les temples d'angkor 7
illinois seront sur la ligne de départ
je reçois trois d'entre elles
elia these isabelle orphée et virginie
pagnot bonsoir mesdames merci d'être
présente pour cette émission alors ça
sera votre première participation vous
représenterez le trio des crazy mothers
et vous courrez notamment pour la
fédération française des diabétiques
alors pour commencer petit tour de table
pourquoi se lancer dans l'aventuré
on va commencer par vous il ya alors
parce que j'ai toujours aimé les voyages
laventure avant même d'être maman
maintenant que je suis maman ça j'ai une
miss un petit peu en pause et puis voilà
c'est le moment nos enfants ont grandi
l'aventuré de nouveau possible et avec
mes deux amis le projet nous plaisait
mutuellement et en plus pour moi c'est
un double challenge parce que je suis
diabétique
donc c'est le moyen de démontrer que
même avec un diabète
il peut quand même allé au bout de ses
rêves effectivement un vrai défi vous
est atteinte d'un variable est de type à
en parler dans un instant je me tourne
vers isabelle pourquoi vous participez à
cette à ce raid je crois qu'à la base
alors vous ne connaissiez pas toutes les
trois alors moi j'ai rencontré il ya
vingt ans quand 90 ème rencontre au
mexique déjà dans le cadre d'un voyage
aventure
donc on ce qui nous relie voilà celle
aventure les voyages donc effectivement
quand il ya m'a parlé de ce raid
amazones et surtout de ce double
challenge puisque entre temps elle est
devenue diabétique elle a découvert son
son diabète
j'ai trouvé le pass le projet vraiment
passionnant et donc je suis rentré dans
l' aventure 110%
et donc je connaissais pas virginie
voilà voilà qui à elles se connaissent
voilà depuis sept ans et je connais et
je les rencontre et au mois deux mois de
mars
du coup pareil oui pourquoi rejoindre
cette aventure on s'est rencontré avec
elle il ya sept ans puisque nono fille
sont à l'école ensemble et quand elle
m'a parlé effectivement du raid
enfin voila j'ai mis très peu de temps à
accepter ça c'est vraiment est qu en
fait pareil à mon amour des voyages
j'avais de la même façon bien peu entre
parenthèses et voilà que j'avais envie
de vivre cette aventure avec il ya donc
j'ai tout de suite accepté
on disait il ya un vrai défi pour vous
de fait de votre diabète c'était
important de ce sens et ce défi
justement oui oui c'était vraiment
important
je suis pas sportive à la base je
l'étais quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai
l'année dernière en 2016 décidé de le
mettre à la course à pied
mais de manière très ludique sans aucune
volonté de faire des exploits autres
j'ai lu le bienfait que ça faisait
justement son mondial est ça un vrai
impact en février donc j'ai découvert le
raid amazones sur facebook et tout de
suite je me suis lancé dans l'aventuré
sans crainte parce que avec les
nouvelles technologies mises à notre
disposition les nouveaux médicaments
le soutien l'aide et l'information
dispensée par la fédération française
des diabétiques
tout est possible justement j'avais vous
relancez sûr cela comment comment c'est
possible on part à l'autre bout du monde
on imagine une compétition quand même
dangereuse pour une personne atteinte de
diabète ça nécessite un certain suivi
c'est pas anodin non plus je peux faire
un des malaises hypoglycémiques ce que
conduit le principe du diabète c'est
qu'on a trop de sucre dans le sang et le
sport fait baisser justement de manière
assez drastiques lorsque nous c'est du
sport un peu à un haut niveau fait
baisser de manière très conséquente le
sucre le taux de sucre dans le sang donc
oui c'est une surveillance ça m'oblige à
m'écouter très fortement mais j'ai des
outils à ma disposition justement pour
pour pallier à ces hauts risques liés à
la hausse port et et la fédération
française des diabétiques est là
justement pour nous aider nous écouter
grâce à eux des nouvelles technologies
sont arrivés sur le marché ont été
disponibles pour les patients les en
remercie grandement
voilà je suis très fier d'aller
représenter je pense que mes deux amis à
c'est pareil et virginie isabelle pas
d'appréhension particulière d'entourer
elia et il va falloir que aussi voulu
prêter main forte sur place pas
personnellement non pas du tout au
contraire parce que déjà on a pris le
temps de s'entraîner ensemble depuis le
mois de mars
de façon régulière et c'est vrai qu'il
ya nous a bien expliqué voilà les
symptômes voilà surveiller aussi aller
en hypo en hyperglycémie donc avec les
cette conscience là du coup enfin voila
on y va vraiment sereinement et on
accompagne avec un plaisir
il appelle un mot sur les deux causes
que vous défendrez sur place donc vous
courrez pour l'association française des
diabétiques la fédération française des
diabétiques est aussi une association de
scolarisation pour les jeunes filles au
cambodge
oui tout à fait donc toutes les
participantes au raid amazones
on est presque 400 total vont courir
donc tout pour la même association qui a
été créée par tina fey faire et qui va
permettre donc de scolariser c'est tout
à l'école de scolariser les petites
filles les plus démunis du cambodge
c'est un projet qui est magnifique et on
est tous très fiers de participer
du coup à ce projet et du coup de voilà
de soutenir cette association
et puis aussi donc on court pour
l'association des diabétiques le diabète
c'est une
c'est la maladie auto immune la plus
connue mais il y en a plein d'autres et
notamment mon fils est atteint aussi
d'une maladie auto immune mais qui n'est
pas connu quand et liam a proposé de
faire voilà ce rallye ça aussi fait écho
en moi et c'est aussi
voilà ce challenge ce dépassement de soi
que il y avait entrepris où je me suis
dit bon effectivement pourquoi pas moi
aussi et ça m'a donné voilà de la force
pour justement faire parler d'eux de ces
gens qui vivent au quotidien avec une
maladie auto immune et qui finalement
arrive à faire des choses comme tout le
monde
voilà alors côté sportif ça sera un
programme très chargé au cambodge six
jours d'épreuves du vtt du canoë kayak
du trech notamment une épreuve de vtt 46
km le jour 5
c'est ça qui vous attend comment comment
on prépare de telles épreuves vous avez
préparé ça comment alors je vous ai suis
un petit peu sur les réseaux sociaux
j'ai vu que vous avez fait ça notamment
sur l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
oui grâce à un grâce à isabelle on a pu
justement profiter de ce super terrain
de jeu donc on a on a récemment
d'ailleurs on a réussi à atteindre les
17 km de course à pied en suivant le
super parcours autour du lac
et puis également le vtt
48km soit km faisable ce qui va être
plus dur c'est d'enchaîner les épreuves
mais parce que c'est vrai qu'on en a
fait un petit rétro planning pour être
prêtes et pour pouvoir faire les
épreuves
voilà et 46 km de vtt les 16 km de
canaux et les 17 km de course après qui
nous inquiétait beaucoup ça on est
maintenant prête mais l'enchaînement va
être voilà le challenge supplémentaire
d'enchaîner sur six jours toutes ces
épreuves il nous reste moins d'une
minute il y avait aussi une préparation
financière ce que partir sur places
coûtaient 15000 euros
vous avez eu grâce à des partenaires
vous avez pu notamment remplir ses
objectifs
effectivement enfin il faut savoir que
dans ta maman on se décide de participer
au raid et le raid lui-même il y a voilà
une grande démarche de recherche de
sponsors parce qu'il ya un assez gros
budget allait chercher et nous on est
parti de pages blanches
donc on a démarché près de 30 à 40
entreprises différentes locales et vaut
aujourd'hui effectivement on tenait
vraiment à les remercier parce que c'est
vraiment grâce à eux qu'on est ici
aujourd'hui qu'on peut participer au
raid amazones voilà donc on en a
pas pouvoir les remonter tous les ans la
liste un ballon on en à caster voilà
donc ils nous ont soutenus au delà de
l'aspect financier il nous on s'occupe
vraiment depuis le départ depuis le
début de notre démarche
il a également organisé en parallèle une
tombola
on a participé également à de nombreuses
organisations locales comme la brocante
les olympiades
voilà tout ça pour aussi à donner en
contrepartie à nos sponsors de la
visibilité est également sur les réseaux
sociaux
voilà sur toutes les deux ce qu'on veut
postés au quotidien sur radio
d'entraînement et on vous souhaite en
tout cas une belle aventure à toutes les
trois merci d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau et on pourra suivre vos
aventures sur le site internet du raid
amazones qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
tout comme le raid amazones c'est un
grand cru de la fin d'année le 5e salon
des vins et des saveurs et des couleurs
s'est tenu le week-end dernier à
maurepas les fonds qui ont été récoltés
pendant sept organisent cette
manifestation seront reversés à des
oeuvres sociales c'était une
manifestation organisée par le lions
club de la ville cette année notamment
l'ambition d'acheter un chien guide d'un
montant de 20 mille euros à une personne
non voyante marie pannetrat nicolas
kirillovitch et mélanie poker vous faire
goûter
vin bière saucisson il y en avait pour
tous les goûts au 5e salon de mort pas
de quoi en avoir l'eau à la bouche
le salon rassemble et non seulement des
saveurs mais aussi de superbes couleurs
l'occasion pour les exposants de se
faire connaître
l'objectif de ce salon ainsi que de
faire connaître mon produit aux gens
nemours pas également de proposer ma
bière de noël donc c'est une bière qui
est basée sur une route de flandre
ce salon permet aux yvelinois de
découvrir les différents produits locaux
de la région pour beaucoup ignorer la
présence d'élevage et de production dans
le département c'était plutôt de la
curiosité cherchait rien en particulier
mais comme je suis dans le coin depuis
quatre ans
c'était une occasion si voilà de
découvrir un peu ce qui se passait dans
la région le salon est organisé pour la
cinquième fois par l'association
laâyoune ce club
tous les bénéfices sont intégralement
versés à leurs oeuvres sociales
parmi elles la lutte contre
l'illettrisme à l'aide à l'organisation
de la banque alimentaire et du téléthon
mais pas seulement
nous allons aider aussi l'association
valentin haüy pour des financements de
stylos de lecture vocaux numérique
et puis tous les ans on envoie 50 petits
enfants sur une journée récréative des
petits enfants qui ne doivent pas partir
à l'école à en vacances grâce aux gens
qui viennent qui les exposants qui
viennent au salon et ça nous permet de
financer c'est ses oeuvres sociales
elles les visiteurs font donc à la fois
leurs courses de noël mais aussi une
bonne action
l'année dernière le salon avait
accueilli 1500 personnes
un événement qui a rassemblé 7 années
1650 personnes c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal il est à revoir en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]